here's the issue we don't know Tony's
personal financial situation we don't
know if he's good all this guy knows
he's fighting he should just stop
everyone says this about Fighters it's
all he knows it's the only way he feeds
his family well that's on him he didn't
set things up he can't the UFC makes it
very tough Tony would didn't come up
like a Patty pinmill or sugar Shan in
that era where there was twitch and
sponsors like that you limit them to
rebok so that cuts them at the knees but
you want to be Allin to be a world
champion it's this weird thing it's so
easy for go he needs to stop yeah how's
he going to feed his kids you going to
pay for it you going to pay for it I
can't I got to feed my own kids who's
going to cover Tony's bills who's going
to cover his mortgage his car payments
and we're all quick to go he needs to
stop you stop doing the job you're doing
right now and completely reinvent
yourself and not only do that but at the
same time make a living doing it right
away that covers the bills